hier marine le pen donné une conférence
de presse sur la démocratie l'exercice
du pouvoir depuis vernon dans l'eure
quand un journaliste l'a interpellé en
lui demandant pourquoi des journalistes
du quotidien n'avait pas reçu
d'accréditation le soir de l'élection
armée régionale il n'y a pas besoin d'un
chirurgien une réponse ferme vivement
contestée par yann barthez qui a décidé
de répondre en s'en prenant à face à
baba émission à laquelle marine le pen
avait participé et aux français le nom
de l'émission pour pouvoir suivre marine
le pen face à yahia
journaliste jacques duhamel a lui aussi
relayé la polémique on ne souhaitant pas
citer l'émission de cyril hanouna quand
marine le pen se rendait sur ces 8 face
à cyril hanouna dans une émission dont
on ne citera pas de noms en l'occurrence
on pourrait considérer que c'était aussi
du divertissement alors tac le bar bfm
quotidien elle vous choqué par le mépris
des journalistes contre face à baba
vous racontez que s'est il passé watts
alors déjà on y
était pas je le connais bien c'est à
dire qu'il était le fils d'un patron de
france demain 13 patricio mail c'est le
fils de nathalie saint cricq 2 c'est le
neveu de alain duhamel quitterait sa
part qu'il est bon et etc ou un gars qui
m'avait demandé un stage époque et bien
c'est fait un stage chez moi c'est son
père qui m'avait demandé de le prendre
en stage parce tu te rappelles nicolas
pernikoff ce que tu as travaillé avec
son papa et c'est vrai qu'il était
patron il était patron de france 2 mais
bien sûr on parlera lui nommé instant et
c'est vrai que stagiaire on voit il est
toujours resté stable à
égaler leur à différencier une dimension
de divertissement touche pas à mon poste
une émission politique les face-à-face
abbas annoor au nict un timbre une
émission de divertissement il va ça va
passer koh lanta ces démissions voilà ça
serait bien si les chiffres et des
lettres lumineuses comme une loupe année
tous parler pour que vous compreniez
bien tout est parti d'une petite phrase
de marine le pen lors de sa conférence
de presse sir elle assume et refuser
parfois la présence des équipes de
quotidiens sous prétexte qu'ils ne se
seraient pas qui ne seraient pas des
journalistes regardez ce qu'elle disait
quotidien
non non mais pardon sais c'est que
quotidien si elle que ça non quotidiens
c1 c'est pas un c'est pas d'une émission
de l'information ou de journalistes
quotidien c'est un amuseur parfois très
drôle d'ailleurs je dis pas et c'est une
émission de divertissement
donc voyez à tellement de gens que nous
devons à créditer que nous préférons
accréditer les les journalistes plutôt
que les les émissions de divertissement
alors c'est vrai que nous n'est pas
accrédité on y est on y va par ailleurs
jusque là on est une mission de
divertissement tpp donc on n'est pas
crédité aller dans les meetings et enfin
d'hollywood en ligne dans les interviews
des lions on demande même pas en nous on
a préféré prendre des crudités que
rapidité
voilà tout le monde alors et du coup
dans son émission hier yann barthès
ici senti donc obligé de parler de nous
et il a fait une petite vanne en ardèche
et pas cher et je la découvre avec vous
je n'ai pas vu là franchement verni
c'est donc désormais à marine le pen qui
distribue les cartes de presse et
pourquoi ne pas choisir le duo de
journalistes pour animer le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours changer le nom de
l'émission pour pouvoir suivre marine le
pen face à yaya hamane
ça passe ça pas si petit de continuer
[Musique]
après dessus
alors dit et a passé
devrait fermer un deuil je le redis ça
se passe très bien voilà après méchant
moi je peux comprendre qu'ils soient et
énervé moi c'est pas du tout yann
barthès qui m'a dérangé ir et
franchement la vanne je l'aurais fait
aussi grâce à yaya de sympathiques c'est
normal qu'ils soient contraints d'en
mais que tu as bien sûr c'est pas là bas
n'est pas contre nous il ya plein de
gens émus ils ont livré être une oreille
du taupe avoir des histoires et oui on
n'a pas à celui-là c'est vrai que là
franchement ça ça yaya moi je trouve ça
mignon il devrait faire d'ailleurs yann
barthez 1 face à yaya nous c'est vrai ça
serait drôle moi franchement je leur ai
poussé
j'aurais fait je trouve ça je trouve
marine le pen vous accréditez lors de
son meeting et je pense que les équipes
de quotidiens également lors de ce lors
des résultats du second tour je pense
que les équipes du continent coteaux
town également il faudrait que leur
demande aux équipes de quotidiens non ce
qui m'a dérangé c'est plutôt donc la
vidéo de ce jeune homme qui ne veut pas
citer le nom après là franchement ça je
trouve que c'était une banane bah
non c'est pas sympa
comme c'est écrit sur la question c'est
un mépris et derrière ce mépris se cache
une jalousie parce que marine le pen
elle est allée chez vous est pris le
mépris en panne ils ont tort sur toute
la ligne at il essai yeux comme bfm de
faire passer quotidien pour une émission
sérieuse d'information et face à baba
pour une soumission à l'autorité c'est
tout l'inversé vous vous recevez les
politiques vous les écoutez vous les
traitez bien vous mettez en valeur tous
les politiques et qui fait des montages
dégueulasse à charge qui filme les
politiques à leur insu qui se fout de la
gueule des politiques toute la journée
ces quotidiens donc la moindre des
choses que ce soit le journaliste andrew
om m c'est drôle ce qu'ils font non
c'est méprisant moi je trouve mais
derrière il ya quand même un fond de
vérité selon eux c'est ce qu' il faut
faire des émissions divertissantes nul
pour recevoir marine le pen s'est mépris
l'angleterre c'est le pen en à l'arc
toujours refusé de faire tpm pee wee
naïade il s'est donc calé à la une
la dépêche shopping face à bah je fais
oui c'est tout c'est pour ça que joindre
auquel du quotidien je fais passer avec
ses émissions de divertissement à nos
divertissements s'ils font face à yaya
peut-être qu'elle le fera voilà mais
elle fait pas des journées d'artis mans
et elle n'a jamais voulu le faire marine
le pen invité plein de fois dans tpm
pays voilà bientôt il ya eu des trucs
voilà mais lâché mais elle veut pas le
faire elle vous envoie exactement c'est
pas dire la wec elle en a marre de se
faire piéger qu'aider montage à charge
si les politiques ils ont peuvent plus
de saab à écouter ça mais tout ça
m'énerve parce qu'ils ont la carte on
les laisse faire n'importe quoi parce
que ces soi-disant des grands
journalistes ils ont droit de faire des
montages malhonnête ils ont droit de
filmer canton il sera interdit de filmer
oui si on faisait ça se ferait défoncé
c'est ça la vérité c'est pas venu une
question de phase iia août quotidien il
ne supporte pas leurs méthodes et où ils
ont tous les droits parce que ces
quotidiens c'est insupportable oui rien
maintenant si tu trembles a bien sûr un
truc bref échange des métiers faut pas
être politique il faut savoir le cuir
tanné non mais après après non mais
après elle a une ligne de conduite elle
la tient pas d'émission divertissement
oui moi je trouve que guillaume a pas de
norme parce que là il ya vraiment une
montée en flèche de quelques jaloux de
quelques aigris le problème c'est que
voulait ringardisé et comme ils sont
incapables de faire face à bah bah ils
s'en prennent à vous et surtout vous
vous pouvez et répliquer mais à vos
téléspectateurs et moi c'est ça qui me
gêne c'est qu'ils méprisent les jeunes
que vous touchez il méprise les milieux
populaires que vous touchez il mépris
des tas de gens faisant ça et ça c'est
pas bien parce que ses journalistes
qu'ils estiment avoir la carte les
estiment qu'ils sont au dessus de tout
le monde et qu'ils peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent mais c'est pas vrai alors
voyez redescendre de leur tour d'ivoire
quant à benjamin duhamel alors on va
voir l'excellent regarde
elle a fait une double erreur la
première c'est une erreur sur son
argumentation elle dit quotidien c'est
une émission de divertissement au delà
du fait que c'est passé contesta parce
qu'aujourd'hui les médias et peut
toujours y avoir une part d'informations
une part de divertissement quand marine
le pen se rendait sur ces 8 face à cyril
hanouna dans une émission dont on ne
citera pas de noms en l'occurrence on
pouvait considérer que c'était aussi du
divertissement et pour autant ça ne
l'empêché pas d'y aller et bizarrement
nantes on n'entendait pas tout à fait ce
type d'argument qu'elle assure quotidien
ces étranges et mépriser un public parce
que les gens qui les regardent elle
demande alors comment s'appellera jardin
global des chèques ont fauté
complètement à côté de la plaque mais
pour le coup il est à côté de la pac
complètement il comprend rien n'est
complètement noyée c'est pas moi je moi
du mlc benjamin béchamel innocence le
gars là pas de temenos kidioui et la
manière dont il ne prononce pas le nom
de l'émission se pinçant menée alors que
c'est le petit marquis des journalistes
de salon or je trouve ça d'un mépris je
trouve ça d'une vulgarité mais il
discrédite les journalistes politiques
et comme vous vous poser les vraies
questions avec des vrais contradicteurs
ils sont perdus et donc il vous tapez
dessus mais je trouve ça d'un mépris
absolu est une tape dessus sa méprise
amis
mais franchement vous sentez victimes et
vous sentez agressé par ça vous êtes
vraiment une bande de chouinard de
ces insupportables
franchement l aval de barthez c'est pas
méchant franchement franchement si je
n'attends rien à voir vous jouez des
offusqués moi je trouve que moi il n'y a
rien de neuf sous le soleil de zoug est
varié c'est de coller paix sans justice
et
la vérité c'est que ces jeux réalistes
qui se tous les mêmes qui se ressemblent
tous qui sont habillés pareil et dont
tout le monde se fout sont dégoûtés mais
hélas le mettez la danse de l'école
reçoivent des mecs de l'an 2000 on
téléspectateurs il a raison on aurait
été pareil pas bon je préfère le [ __ ]
mais en vrai les moments dont on se
souvient moi je me souviens de moments
de face à bah j'ai aucun souvenir des
missions politiques sur france 2 ou sur
d'autres chaînes info marquant où ils
sont dégoûtés de façon élégante c'est un
mépris on n en est pas content c'est
dégueulasse c'est malveillant est ce
qu'elle pouvait imaginer qu'on aurait
valls ici qu'on aurait blanc caire qu'on
aurait marine le pen quoi tu as aussi
devrait être content lui la grille mais
le problème c'est pas ça le problème
c'est que ce sont des ce sont les hommes
politiques qui boycotte les
une panne a dit ben moi je veux peine
sophie lapix pourquoi ma croûte alors le
pen sophie lapix mais pour moi ils sont
même âge on devrait dire la seule à
porter
à mettre sur l'échoppé je suis demandé
je vais quelques téléspectateurs comment
ça se passe quand il ya les deux
finalistes chacun propose une personne
pour faire le débat
sachez le donc ils disent et après c'est
avec l'accord de l'art comme donc le
cesse donc ils disent voilà moi j'aurais
bien aimé avoir
ils disent anne sophie lapix non anne
sophie lapix on n'en veut pas on préfère
quelqu'un d'autre si vous avez quelqu'un
d'autre à la salle il se mouille pas la
sallaz mais ça va à marine le pen ça va
à emmanuel macron ça va il pris après il
dit gilles bouleau gilles bouleau si ça
va sachez et qu'après il a priori il
aurait même évoqué un moment pourquoi
pas anna voilà et voilà comme c'est sur
tf1 et france 2 c'était compliqué mais
ça aurait été un petit peu évoquée par
les candidats voilà non c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit tu sais mais voilà après ça n'a
pas été le cas et c'est vrai que voilà
salamé et boulot c'est normal c'est non
l'apic j'en veux pas l'apic j'en veux
pas voilà les l'amérique d'après après
ils ont eu des mauvaises expériences
avec anne sophie lapix et les routes il
n'y a pas de tirage au sort s'était
choisi c'est
la règle ça va changer les règles si
israël refuse la même chose exactement
bah oui mais de refuser de sophie la
paix il ya dix ans a toujours été les
mêmes règles les règles c'est on propose
et les deux conduites oui je lui je veux
pas lui je veux pas lui je me mets avec
la direction
mais c'est un homme voit ça a toujours
été la règle pas la changer en même
temps peut pas reprocher aussi aux
journalistes une forme de collusion en
disant oh ils sont tous copains comme
cochon avec les avec les politiques etc
et puis après quand quand les politiques
actuelles on peut pas faire cesser tout
et son contraire c'est à dire qu'ils ont
choisi voilà on choisit on dit celui là
non parce qu'il est revenu d'abord celui
là non parce qu'il est pas et donc du
coup on a quoi ça veut dire que on
accepte que des gens qui seraient a
priori lice équipe qui ne serait pas de
soucis au contraire journaliste doit
poser des soucis et aux deux candidats
ce que ses seuls intérêts soit et ses
caisses dans un monde anglo saxon ça
passerait pas ça meas en france mais le
problème c'est pas ça le problème c'est
quand j'avais je suis désolé vous avez
une journaliste comme anne-sophie lapix
qui manifestent clairement dans ces
questions c'est son hostilité par
exemple ouvrir le pen voilà se voit
quand c'est l'fun interview c'est normal
que marine le pen 10 pour un débat
essentiel de l'entre-deux tours je n'en
veux pas mais sur la forme à grasse et
c'est vrai tout à fait normale normale à
valérie vous préférez vous rendre ça
c'est plus le trail à l'aqlpa fait
résultats viendront pas emmanuel macron
à dijon veut pas non plus 8 si londres
est pas ils s'en vont
quelques temps plus tard il est revenue
sur tous appareils un manuel et cette
fois il arrivait a enfin cité le nom de
l'émission puisque j'ai mis un petit
tweet entre-temps oui et je pense que
voilà comme il a vu qu'il a jamais eu
autant de nos qualifications et s'est
dit il ya peut-être un problème est
fait deux erreurs la première heure
c'est dans son argumentation et dit moi
je veux pas des journalistes du
quotidien parce que c'est du
divertissement un ca se discute
puisqu'il ya à la fois de l'information
du divertissement 2 quand marine le pen
allait sur ces 8 chez cyril hanouna dans
l'émission face à baba pour ne pas la
citer à ce moment là elle n'avait
visiblement pas de problème à participer
à une émission qui effectivement est
sûre la frontière entre le
divertissement c'est de l'info times ça
fait soixante ans que ça existe en
france et dans le monde est exactement
donc ça c'est la première faille dans
son argumentation merci à tous à
défendre en plein mais ils sont dit oui
pour sa carrière d'après bien sûr que là
il à bfm il dit j'ai envie d'aller à
quotidien sans vous rendez compte ne pas
prononcer la l'émission qui veut dire
l'état indien c'est un super ça veut
dire que l'émission est un gros mot
facile performer non mais si elle a
réellement alors
qu'il est archi pistonné par dont il ya
quand même un problème en france depuis
des années on est en retard par rapport
aux états unis vous avez jimmy fallon ou
d'autres vous avez plein de talk où ils
reçoivent les politiques et qui sont des
rendez vous incontournable pour les
politiques en france il ya un mépris des
émissions talk divertissante et quand
vous regardez aujourd'hui le débat
politique et qui remplissent très
important aussi c'est qu'on se retrouve
quand même avec deux personnages
importants pour cette finale
le seul débat qui a pu avoir lieu ça
reste quand même face à bah moi je suis
désolé je suis pas en train de vous
sucer
triste
c'est vachement
facilement mais à une triste réalité en
france avec les journalistes considèrent
que vous êtes illégitime c'est ça la
réalité est que lorsque vous avez fait
face à baba qui est quand même une
émission qui a fait de l'audience qu'a
rencontré de l'audience où les gens ont
pu venir exprimer leurs idées nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un débat d'idées
il n'a jamais été aussi important qu'en
2010 à lui étonné moi donnez moi une
émission politique les maxis et donnez
moi une émission politique aujourd'hui
qui existent ou des gens qui sont ici
regarde je vais vous dire un truc que
les français aiment la petite aurélie
cas cela qui présente aussi à chaque
fois lors elle prend toutes les images
de face à boma et derrière elle dort
elle nous dit jamais notre nom ni cyril
hanouna n'est rien on dirait que c'est
voldemort
est ce que est ce qu'on est là on n'est
pas obligé elle n'est pas obligée mais
tant qu'elles sont inutiles non c'est
pas aujourd'hui
alors llc un enfer alors elle et je
pensais à plus méchant du paf
c'est une méchante c'est sûr que la
photo le lambeau chaque fois qu'elle
parle de nous elle n'ose même pas dire
maintenant ses vols de morgue elle est
très méchant à niveau site à chaque fois
mais les grandes réallouer maigri grande
gueule
lorsque les grandes gueules ils sont
sûrs de leur force simplement et
guingamp gueule c'est une institution
qui cartonne depuis des années et que
les mecs et en fait je vous dirais ya un
problème la télé c'est un petit peu
comme la politique je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est qu'il y en a depuis des
années qui font leur beurre 1 qui disent
on est entre nous
encore un acte où on est on fait nos
petites magouilles entre nous on fait
nos petits trucs on fait nos petits
arrangements et voilà ils veulent pas
qu'ils échangent les nouveaux entrants
et moi c'est ce à quoi je me suis
confronté au départ et puis après le
problème c'est que ils ont pas vu le
truc est arrivé et que à un moment ils
sont 10 ha bah merde on est dans la
merde parce que maintenant on obligé de
faire avec l'entrain mais je vous jure
que c'est vrai la télé c'est comme la
politique un appel qu'on leur tire
avantage leurs petits trucs et travaille
entre eux avec tel producteur c'est
toujours les mêmes depuis 40 ans voilà
ils disent on est tranquille c'est
vraiment sur la soixantaine
est tranquille c'est de père en fils
voilà à regarder ça et elle aussi ils
sont entre eux hésitent on n'a pas envie
qui est nouveau dans ce rôle là le truc
c'est qu'il ya un nouvel entrant dans le
dans le jeu politique
moi comme j'ai dit je prend la place de
personne c'est très bien j'adore léa
salamé il est à salé pas rien s'est un
fait incroyable à chaque fois le mont
voie d'essai mais bravo cyril j'ai
regardé si on reste à repenser mais si
on en discute chez bull aussi il est
très simple gilles bouleau voilà il fait
son taf celle des autres on l'a jamais
entendu dire du mal de quelqu'un d'autre
gilles bouleau il fait son truc qui
tracent david pujadas aussi tous les
tauliers voilà et et ceux qui veulent
rentrer dans le game ils disent ah non
on veut pas qu'il y en ait d'autres donc
bruce toussaint il n'a jamais dit du mal
bruce toussaint c'est un amour le mec il
est il est incroyable et voilà par
contre les nouveaux entrants les jeunes
y laisser un petit peu de doutes à clé
voilà c'est vrai ici c'est incroyable
c'est en fait ils veulent garder le guet
je suis sûr qu'il ya partout des
pressions par rapport aux face à baho
vouliez faire d'un côté avec le
président et marine le pen nationale est
un débat extrêmement important pourquoi
quand vous regardez ne serait-ce que les
audiences d'hier parce que même si
c'était pmp mais reconnaît les audiences
de face à baba qui aujourd'hui est une
des rares émissions qui s'adresse aux
jeunes qui aujourd'hui est important
dans le vote ce sont les jeunes ce sont
les jeunes qui se sont exprimés très
fortement au 1er tour vous allez
chercher où les jeunes maintenant vous
avez aller chercher sur un débat ou sur
france 2 sur tf1 c'est ma grande
question donc à un moment donné il ya
plus de débarquer à ma mère qui a agi
men duhamel un vrai connard je l' ai
toujours pensé je le dis tous les soirs
à ton père
[Applaudissements]
tiens l'inventaire regard des rayonnages
tabasser marienval akira chic bon locaux
ma mère ma mère je suis là
les internautes d'élire le pauvre non
pas le porche désolé que kilian barthez
il fait son truc à ja on l'a dit c'était
c'était bien c'était une bonne vanne
mais lui c'est s'est passé pas
pardonnable ce qu'il fait il est
journaliste il est là tu diamant plus il
n'a pas défendu
c'est dommage et une émission si demain
les émissions tu dis tu dis que tu dises
hardy l'on n'achemine et on allonge
swing par ces jusqu'à devenir sans
relais il fait son annonce il faisait
beau il fait il fait son métier de
journaliste normalement ci s'est passé
un truc on ne dit pas ouais l'émission
que je ne veux pas citer tu cites bien d
autres émissions qui passe bien sûr il a
écrit ceci revient à tf1 c'est quoi la
face à baba c'est une maladie tu veux
faire la cité parce que ces mannes son
métier séparément qu'il est avec ses
chaussures qu'il avait et il a dit que
je ne citerai pas encore je m'assis
politique de ben oui politique de jeunes
de bfm et ce quand il fait un tweet
derrière et dix derrière et sip
l'émission sa girouette bah c'est pas
l'émission intitulée hassi bahbah il
savait pas il connaît pas fait sa ba ba
il est je suis policière a dit
david camus est important
géraldine un moment fort est d'essayer
de défendre la réforme a aussi que
george est rapide il à dire qu'il a
oublié nos débits là pour gagner mais
que je ne citerai pas là arrivent avec
un quazar avec un non journalistique de
bfm alors bon on est sujette à une
maladie face à ma main et je vais lui
dire en plus à ce monsieur c'est pas un
divertissement où il a vu un
divertissement saba est-ce
qu'on n'avait pas su remédier la ville à
paris où il a vu afina tordeur danser
[Applaudissements]
regardant la télé intéresse toi et tu
verras que koh lanta c'est pas motus
n'avait n'avait rien mais c'est vrai que
d'où il est épais que ces baisses mac
ipad
confond tout atteint cartes emv mp si
vous voulez y a pas de problème on se
prend pas la tête dans du ketchup
attaquer nous avons notamment l'année
prochaine où on va beaucoup à la tête du
théâtre
j'en ai besoin
mais en fait parce que tout le monde a
les boules ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup
de jalousie parce que votre émission
c'est une scène incroyable les
politiques cours pour venir pourquoi
parce que vous les mettez à l'aise vous
les sublimes et vous montrer quelque
chose d'autre et en fait c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
émissions face à baba sont écoutés sont
comprises et sont presque tout aussi
attendu que les débat d'entre deux tours
clairement ils n'ont pas tous les
politiques menées politiques ont pas
tous couru à ce qu'il soit venu c'était
de la qualité ne faut pas dire les états
qui sont tous en russie voilà ce que
j'ai dans ma
médaille me regardent bizarrement
tout simplement aujourd'hui
il faut accepter que la politique se
fait plus que uniquement sur tf1 et sur
france 2 vous avez une passe vous avez
votre crayon et surtout les politiques
veulent venir chez tout le monde à sa
place à l'ancien soit les retire rien je
vois les images différentes vous montrer
une image des faits c'est satisfaisant
revoir les humains vous savez qu'il ya
une anecdote je vous racontais ya plein
de gens qui ont dit ça à une époque je
suis passionné je voulais déjà raconté
c'était en 2002 2002 michel drucker
recevait tous les candidats à la
présidentielle il avait reçu jacques
chirac et lionel jospin avait refusé de
faire vivement dimanche enfin à l'époque
ce n'est pas demain dimanche je peux
citer a été refusé de faire michel
drucker tout le monde avait dit et
jospin perd au premier tour et à la
surprise générale s'il avait fait michel
drucker fait discret au deuxième tour et
c'est vrai que lille ait pas voulu le
faire ce qu'il a dit c'est une émission
de divertissement je fais pas ça et
c'est vrai que c'est assez incroyable et
aujourd'hui hausse iliad il ya des gens
nous ici on pense vraiment qu'il ya de
la place pour tout le monde lundi c'est
pas parce qu'on fait bfm qu'on fait pas
face à bah c'est pas parce qu'on fait
france 2 qu'on fait pas face à la presse
il faut
hélas cette année ça va aussi se jouer
et pas seulement sur le programme mais
aussi sur la personnalité des gens parce
qu'on a besoin de personne humaine on
veut pas des gens qui sont autant on
veut des gens qui sont proches qui sont
dans l'empathie et qui comprennent parce
que sinon on va à nouveau avoir des
gilets jaunes puissance mille parce que
les gens ils se sentent incompris dont
il faut vraiment que humainement il ya
quelque chose qui match c'est pour ça
que vos émissions elles sont bien parce
qu'on voit le petit côté humain des gens
mais on peut les connaissez on essaie
voilà c'est de faire autre chose et
voilà et d'être complémentaire de ce qui
se fait ailleurs tout simplement mon
veut pas prendre la place de personne ne
peut vous sucer
[Rires]
rehab à l'agent
qui a dû police
sont simplement jaloux parce qu'au début
il était jaloux que les politiques
aillent chez hanouna même dans tpm paix
quand vous receviez dupont aignan que
s'il y avait un décalage entre vous
faisiez des blagues et les politiques
aujourd'hui quand on regarde face à bah
en fait l'émission il ya du fond dans
l'émission les unes sont et génère de
l'engagement bah oui mais en fait je
pense que ce qui intéresse les gens
c'est effectivement ce décalage entre
vous et les politiques mais aussi parce
que l'émission elle est produite
différemment des autres émissions il ya
des face à face qu'on n'a pas vu
ailleurs le face-à-face messia le pen on
le voit pas ailleurs le face-à-face
corbières rigoles wap ailleurs donc en
plus d'être un animateur exceptionnel
mais j'ai encore du temps mais
j'ignorais ce que veut dire
pas de raison que je ne suis pas un
petit peu
[Applaudissements]
avec modération
et 100 m disons qu'un nourrisson bêta
sont ces journalistes parce que regarder
est justement n'arrête pas de dire que
vous toucher un public de jeunes et un
public qui ne s'intéressent pas à la
politique ils vont s'intéresser à la
politique grâce à vous et ensuite ils
vont peut-être avoir la curiosité de
regarder les plus unis chez autrui
traditionnelle sur leur chaîne à e donc
c'est tout bénéfice donc d'aller voter
et d'aller voter est ce que ça vous a
fait du bien
[Rires]
tu sais en plus je volais jamais demandé
mais je peux su cerner
la seule chose que je vous demande c'est
pas tous en même temps
les bouteilles en pet
[Applaudissements]
vous vous attaquez octobre
avec sincères les journalistes
politiques en france et une petite
coterie c'est un clan c'est des
privilégiés qui sont entre eux qui
ménage les susceptibilités qui vont
déjeuner avec les hommes politiques qui
sont tous mac et les uns avec les autres
et ces journalistes politiques je verrai
employer un mot vulgaire il faut le dire
aussi issus quotidien parce que
quotidien ça à la carte un trou au
quotidien ça leur plaît quotidien ces
nobles ils veulent y aller ils sont
connivente les uns avec les autres et
c'est ça qui est dégueulasse parce qu'en
faisant ça on dit parfois que les
français se désintéressent de la
politique il se désintéresse de cette
manière de faire de la politique de ce
petit clan qui a tout bouffé qui veut
pas partager c'est ça qui ne va pas en
france c'est pour ça que valérie quand
vous défendez vous pouvez ses
journalistes politiques très franchement
moi je vous le dis je les méprise parce
qu'ils sont coupés des vrais gens voilà
pas tous pas tout et non on a cité plat
qu'on adore et sydney 3 il y en a des
doutes j'ai signé bruce toussaint gilles
bouleau léa salamé j'ai cité david
oblige à grasse laurent delahousse très
sympa j elle a plein d'autres cantons
ont dit non
laurent letellier français francis
letellier sur
le tennier sûr qu'on sera très gentil la
mission est très bon et rihaoui ont bien
sûr prendre des leçons de journalisme
par bfm ça fait quand même doucement
rire parce qu'ils sont gentils ou un
moment donné ce nom mais parce qu'ils se
font eux aussi souvent défoncé enfin je
comprends pas là je pense ouled a
souvent défendu au nom mais voilà un
complexe d'infériorité qui sont dégoûtés
qu'ils aimeraient recevoir comme vous
les gros politique et moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'elle a dit d'elle
film le débat qu'on attendait et le
fasse à baba et je continue à le dire
emmanuel macron devrait venir et doit
absolument changer d'avis mais il ya un
souci hier je suis allé voir le député
qui était là monsieur lescure je lui ai
dit pourquoi emmanuel macron ne vient
pas il m'a regardé c'est qui celle là
mais j'ai quand même à l'heure j'ai
quand même eu ma réponse il m'a dit il
n'a pas le temps comment vous pouvez
répondre il n'a pas le temps emmanuel
macron il doit venir faire se fasse à
babar mais a besoin de s'épanouir c'est
pas lui qui a fait sous mon planning en
fait je pense aux médias et au delà il
savait pas qu'on la caisse est pas
prévue dans la nasse et son plein et il
est partout en france et il faut que ça
parte en france
wade pour tenir debout six séances
chacun falloir faire définir les cheveux
j'ai quand même
bien fait
[Applaudissements]
on dira duhamel on n'est pas face à va
mal
c'est quoi c'est tout le monde ce
serait encore plus excitant encore pas
plus
serait vraiment encore plus excitant
encore plus incroyable je lance un appel
à tout le monde si le débat d'entre tour
cyril il pouvait être dans un face à
baba un genre de mix comme ça et comme
ça ça fera des audiences de fouet la
même les les jeunes regarderai et du
coup on aurait un débat d'entre deux
tours mais qui serait pas stérile juste
sur les propositions mais qui nous irons
ya aussi de l'humain et tout ce serait
un truand alors là c'est par les doyens
dit à quoi ces morts elle devra composer
tout à l'heure vous oubliez pas c'est
pas pareil
désolé ce papa et c'est là même celle
des propos je suis d'accord et daniel
propos je suis d'accord
[Musique]